ONE GUY COVERING THE PUCK
CA TO FEED.
>> Mickey: NO GOES TO THE
LINE ANDE TO INTERCEPT.
>>
SAGINAW SPIRITS  STOPPED.
AND OUT TO DRAISAITL AGAIN.
TORONT OF THE
NET.
ERNE, AND GIVANI SMITH A BREAK.
GAGNER,D,
EDMONTON CAUGHT WITH ONE
DEFENSEMAN PITCHING RIGHT ONE.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> AND OUT IN
FRONT.
THEY SCORE!
HIS LEFT ARM IS BEING LEDDY OVE
FABBRI GETTING IT TOUCK
WOULDN'T GO FOR HIM.
STAAL GIVES HIM ANOTHER ATTEMPT
>> SAM GAGNER.
>> HE JUST BEARED DOWN FAST.
>> KEEP HOPING.
>> I MEAN SAYS
RETRIEVING PUCKS TONIGHT.
THIS WILL COME BACK DEKEYSER.
D
HE'S REALLY BECOMING A POWER  FL
THE S S AWAY AT IT, LARKIN
AGAIN.
NURSE ALL THE WAY TOASSISTS, 23
MCDAVID.   ICING AGAINST
EDMONTON.  CHECKED AWAY.
LARKIN FOR  THAT NOT HAPPEN?
>> HE WAS ON A LINE 10 BELL SAV
LEG.
NUGENT-HOPKINS TO GET IT.
DOWN LOW THEY GO, MCDAVID, PUCKE